[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
hello everybody
what's up
happy friday
uh i finally just got in we were
actually trying to start at 10
um
i think we got some
social arena all right bot arena we
definitely want to play some social
games let's take a look at the game list
because they mentioned
that sometime throughout
the next two weekends i think next
weekend is big team battle yo what's
good brandon what's good steven what's
good sammy pizza gaming shorty
everyone what's good how's it going
tried to get as many names as i've seen
in there
um
but yeah what is good voice is too low
all right let me turn it up a little bit
i don't want it to be too loud this mic
is extremely sensitive and if i turn up
the notch even the slightest bit
it goes haywire so
i'm gonna
uh i don't wanna kill y'all's ears this
mic is so sensitive
but there we go i'm gonna leave it there
i see the voice lines going into the
yellow territory which i feel is
phew
way up there especially when i start
going crazy in the match like ah
but yeah all right we've got arena
slayer this weekend i think next weekend
is btb but
let's hop in there
i know i'm excited for multiplayer i
know in the last technical preview they
definitely
tossed in some
no
here we go last time they definitely
tossed in like
one
little batch of multiplayer
where you played against real people at
the end of the preview
definitely interesting
um obviously way more difficult with the
bots like when we played against the
bots we didn't really lose any matches
but obviously once we got up against
real people the elves started coming in
he started understanding more about the
maps and stuff like that there's a lot
of other changes though i'm interested
in seeing wondering if
um
they're implementing those new radar
changes into this as well so
audio's good now well thank you thank
you
all right we loaded in this time
[Music]
anybody else in the chat get into the
technical preview
have you seen it at all
okay recharge this was one from one of
these
[Music]
from the last preview we did play on
this one
yes let's go
i do enjoy these little intros here
though
wait
is
one second comes
lost the lead
i don't know how that happened i i'm
pretty sure i was playing on default
last time
but yeah
taking damage
i have been playing a lot of halo 2 so
i'm definitely going to be oh that's why
i changed button
or not on
whatever
oh
there we go
no i was waiting for that vr
[Music]
well then
i saw some really cool tech that was
shared though after the last preview
with the slide jumps on ramps and
everything
i was like yeah
like which is odd because i play a lot
of apex and that is how you edius
but it feels so different when it's a
halo game
um
[Music]
it's okay we picked this trace again
this is all
[Music]
the
oh
i actually didn't get to use this weapon
that much
i really want to br though
oh get over here
throwing a sticky
right
is not on point right now
i'm playing hide and seek
with this person
please
um
oh
i didn't even see him on my radar
i wish i could paint i'll paint yourself
i don't remember oh yeah i got it right
yeah
it's like nice and weird
five minutes
instead of throwing a grenade again
oh
the muscle memory is too strong
i swear i'm trying to use the grenades
but i keep absing on accident
oh no
okay okay
all right this was warm-up browns
i think it definitely makes sense like
grappling hooks so you have to pick them
up off the map
but that usually means libraries
all right
that was definitely a big defeat
but it's okay
i love the music and the audio on this
too ice cream
[Music]
um
[Music]
i will say though i feel like halo
infinite when you watch it
it feels a lot different
you know when you're actually playing it
than how it looks so
that's something else to keep in mind
too because i think early footage i saw
of the payload and i was like hmm i
wonder if it's really going to feel like
you know the gunshots are going to feel
impactful and stuff like that because
just by watching it for the first time i
couldn't really sell but after playing a
bit
definitely i'm enjoying it for sure
[Music]
hey thanks p i'm glad you're tuning in
and i'm glad all of you are tuning in
i know they said that they sent like a
lot more invites out for
these next few weekends and that they're
still going to be sending invites out
over the course of the week
that a lot more people are going to be
able to get in so
i mean chris jones you're not wrong halo
definitely looks like halo
like this definitely
yeah the controls are taking me a little
bit to get used to but
thanks
hopefully i think there's three maps uh
zero i think there's three maps
um
that are on this playlist right now and
then next weekend the btv
i believe is gonna have the new map
like that even though i've definitely
been absolutely demolished
long greens with the pistols up there
i i'm just not like oh no voodoo
[Music]
my prescription needs updating
oh no
not
[Music]
trying to try to shoot
hey we actually managed to get much
faster
oh
i might have to turn that off i don't
usually play with hovercraft but
[Music]
yeah
you're the best
it was not in vain
another one down
um i have to remember the beers one
is not my first time
oh
oh
i'm scared
[Music]
i need to implement that
instead of taking the stairs
my own
[Music]
that was terrifying
that was terrible
oh
i'm actually excited to see
if they're gonna put like slayer vr
oh
[Music]
victories
the spike grenade power items on the way
okay
is
facelift buddy system no longer
all right
i know december 8th on december 8th if
you're not in the flight right now
the game doesn't stop
not that far
[Music]
we're getting challenges
[Music]
yeah i definitely think halo's overall
like skill
skill skill
skill sealing is gonna be higher this
time around definitely because we're
gonna have some awesome keyboard players
on board we got
console players we've been playing for
like all these years since the first
halos
pretty cool
um and for those of you wondering
how you can play because next weekend is
also
another weekend of tech testing that's
going to include big team battle you can
still sign up at halowaypoint.com for
the halo insider program and you kind of
have to fill out a bunch of information
and give them the
specifics of either your console or your
pc
and you have to opt in so there's a few
steps you actually have to do when you
sign up that a lot of people didn't
realize i think at first
so they weren't actually fully signing
up so just make sure you have all that
stuff done to you and
they said in their live stream this past
week that in writes were still going to
be going out over this whole
oh no
i think rockets spawn under that area
under the stairs actually or is it on
the
did the rocket blow me backwards that
was interesting
i remember
three for three on the rocket kills i
might be
actually
crud
i just picked up the vr
card break
heart
oh
[Music]
grapple shot acquired
that's why i can't rely too much on the
needs because if i run out i'm doing
nothing
hail
say you can also run in this game even
if your shields are low and your chills
will come back so that's something a
little different from halo 5
spike obtained
actually
let me do the smarter things
oh
i think my teammate on top died
oh man i really need to shoot slower
[Music]
okay
uh
the lead
right here
[Music]
i don't know why i wasn't ready for that
i think i partially knew that someone
was going to come from that direction
france isn't ready
oh
rest in peace
my vr power items up for grabs
right
oh
[Music]
he zipped in there with a mission
and that mission was accomplished
actually
five minutes remaining
nearing victory
oh i saw that guy on the right let's not
beat
oh i see him
we can get him we can get him teamwork
yes
even though one of us did
get sacrificed it's fine
oh
because
i cannot survive without them
i can't okay rocket guys we're in there
i got your back dude
yeah let's go
buddy systems
autobots roll out
don't fear my teammate with rockets
oh no
millionaires
we did
um orange yes this is coming out on
december 8th that is
[Music]
um
i mean but you know how things go
sometimes
but they did say i remember they were
saying during their livestream that this
might be delayed
but it wasn't so i think december 8th
isn't a good spot at the moment
and in case anybody forgot
you can play the multiplayer
for free the multiplayer is going to be
free to play when it comes out
and the campaign is going to be on game
pass
i think game pass is dope i don't know
i
love me some game pass night storm
what's up welcome to the stream
yeah i think co-op and porridge are
coming after lunch sometime
[Music]
hopefully we get to try
um
actually i need to check the list again
to see if that other mouth is sending it
might not be
i did see a video of a bot teabagging
someone and
uh during the last preview but i don't
think it was an intentional just ended
up looking like that but that was pretty
funny
i think if that happened
i killed everything that moves try not
to die
on that pistol
weapon
explosion
watch my back
killing spree
nothing satisfies like a three-round
first
i'm proud of you heck i'm proud of us
hey thanks spear
i appreciate that
enemy
i got more right here
overshield available
[Music]
i don't want to turn my sensitivity down
because it's pretty slow
but my end
up close especially
there's so many explosions
[Music]
watch my back
um
[Music]
yeah he's over here
[Music]
this is the perry one i thought i picked
up the grappler
wrong one
actually i think i didn't use this one
last speeding this uh that's already
really curious oh
that was so cool
[Music]
i should
i definitely think though
so far for me personally the vr thing
my best weapon
oh no
i can't help it
no
[Music]
don't go afk in the beta there's so many
people over there
oh
the gravity hammer is terrifying okay i
wasn't scared of it when i was playing
against bots but real people terrible
i wonder what that is when just their
face starts alone
[Music]
taking fire
thank goodness i spawned immediately
right next to the oh wow
[Music]
oh
[Music]
yes
even though i was hoping it would be an
assassination it wasn't
even
[Music]
we are unlocking stuff
oh wait i just want to take a look at
bizarre recharge and live right yeah
okay
same maps as last time actually
[Music]
yeah i feel like that's just halo
culture right everyone's like man i got
steak-taculared well i'm a tea bag the
team anyways even though they
they beat us
let's just take a way of life apparently
yo bob jones what's good
i see you over in the twitch chat how's
it going long time no see i hope you've
been well hoping you're having a very
nice friday
we are playing some halo infinite
um
i'm struggling right now but i'm having
a good time
two shreds you say
you'll increase damage to vehicles by
shooting off their tires
well
[Music]
that in mind for next weekend i think
it's next weekend honestly if you want
the actual details of everything that's
going to be in this weekend's and next
weekend's technical preview go to
gamespot.com
we got it all over there
even the multiplayer hours are only
between specific windows anyways so
okay
let's be the best
no not so smashed pick it up
the radio sounds really amateur
thing is not very white
[Music]
i want to
try to put
or something like that it was something
wild in the video
but really fun to do but
i don't really know how to do it i just
saw a quick video clip
nothing satisfies like a three-round
that is literally true
[Music]
reloading
[Music]
i miss so many shots
thank you see me
active okay i'm gonna be able to do it
what a shock
i'm not good at contesting in vr with a
pistol but
they definitely
[Music]
new halo teams popping up for internet
i can't wait to watch
some of the free tournaments
thank you
don't worry i got your back hopefully ow
oh no oh no
no oh i'm clicking okay i didn't realize
my camera
[Music]
your knees
kids
[Music]
okay they definitely turned off friendly
fire
which is amazing
that i bet you so many people were
getting betrayed by teammates
that they were like all right friendly
fire needs to
go honestly
oh
silly me
i'm trying to get over to the vr spawn
but
it's not happening chief grenade
[Music]
i did not realize there was another one
you're just gonna leave the battle rifle
here
keep spawning so far away from it too
no
my pre-fire not effective
[Music]
all right
though it's not
available
right
surprised
[Music]
all right
[Music]
[Music]
pretty sure these are all just cosmetic
though
[Music]
oops
there we go
right back in there
let's go
[Music]
nice you're logging in sweet good luck
have fun
who else is playing some
uh some of this halo infinite this
weekend who else got into the halo
insider program
because
there's still time to sign up
if you're not in otherwise december 8th
right around the corner
i ain't afraid deal damage to ghosts and
flying beagles by destroying their wings
i mean yeah that makes sense right if
they're flying things and have no wings
these oh
new the cube before your fusion coils
can be picked up
[Music]
i forgot about those
hello hipster welcome to the stream i'll
see you in the twitch chat
not my favorite among the three but
i like the wheels
[Music]
you're a lifesaver
hold down
some sections of the map here
formulate some teamwork
or maybe they died already
more likely
has got it all under control over there
um yeah my teammates are just crashed
like a three-round burst
we are playing some serious ring around
the roses
um and once again i said nothing
because an absolute
beast
oh my audio
close but no cigar
okay
no wonder
it was really slow none another from
left they're all leaving
oh does one nate destroy the whole
shield that's pretty cool
that's good to know
do they re-input people into the lobby
no i don't think enemies
[Music]
obtained
hmm
he's right next to you yoshi please
yeah there you go
i guess i should have pinged would you
have seen my thing
whoa very great
wait
the only way i can get a vr one half of
the other team
[Music]
with the rockets
oh man
i need to turn off toggle crouch
on the way
i want to try it now
wow
41 spanker is a god
oh yeah in case you don't know there is
a
a glitch
it's kind of like the bx being from halo
2 but it's with a wide
charging machines
oh
yay another game where my clambering is
gonna be
awful
[Music]
looks fun
[Music]
this has been probably the longest
game of infinite i've ever power items
inbound
oh you're doing the glitch on everyone
it looks so funny though
wow
i will do that later i will go into
trading mode later and learn it
i don't think everyone knows that
friendly fire isn't on so
yeah we've got the m41 spanker
the spanker
that's the way you pronounce that huh
what a hilarious thing
i honestly
would have just been like yo rockets
oh it's the longest game
my background
it looks like some people
they have five on their side
like maybe it did try to repopulate the
game with somebody when the first person
oh
[Music]
all right we did our first vyde
[Music]
[Music]
hopefully like a full game with all the
players that'd be great
that would be great
man watching
that guy byb everybody from far away
definitely was an experience
[Music]
all right what's it gonna be
which map were we heading to
[Music]
um
taking a little wild load
but
hopefully we will be okay
[Music]
oh there we go
i mean i'm definitely the type of player
where it takes me a while to get
comfortable with the game
but i'm still having a good time
there's probably a little bit more
tinkering i could do with my sensitivity
oh i got
i got the guy who was destroying my
whole team on my team this time
i hear the name
didn't realize
lost the lead
what a shot
what a shot
[Music]
we're going quiet
oh
[Music]
available
let me get next team
uh
they're so terrifying
the second i see it in the air heading
my direction
i'm
shook some damage
so many explosions in here
[Music]
oh
um
victory
they're literally all here
no water gamer
no
watch my back
oh someone
or was that the shield going away
[Music]
the beat down lunge range is not that
far so i think everyone's still kind of
used to old
what a place
i think
oh i'm lost i'm lost we're lost
good job
oh okay elizabeth
one time i did want the spikes
uh sorry lisa
um darn every time i pick up the vr
swift
and precise death
nothing satisfies like a three rounds
oh
i didn't even know that was not my
teammate that's how
i thought it was this guy
oh my goodness this game is
close because my camo inbound
active camo available
how we
[Music]
that was super close
vernon don't worry they are still
accepting sign ups for halo insider
all the way through the next week until
next weekend's data period too so if you
feel like
you
want to sign up and it's the times right
now you actually felt like so
[Music]
all right super fun
i am gonna have to call it on that one
but thank you guys so much for tuning in
we're definitely going to be playing
some more over the next few weekends
maybe there will be another stream here
maybe not not sure i actually want to
try to get like a bunch of game spot
people in because i think a few of us
got
access to the technical data this time
around so
um
and i agree solid snake i like using the
br way more than i like using the pistol
my pistol game is not strong right now
but hey
you know when when the game drops on
december 8th we're gonna hit the lab
we're gonna practice and we're gonna try
to step it up for next time um you know
especially when you play in a lot of
older halos definitely feels different
but it feels like they're trying to keep
up with
how shooters are nowadays but still
keeping their halo estimation that's not
easy to do so
i hope you guys have enjoyed the stream
and i'll see you
next time peace out
you